we're going to take some more calls here
we are taking calls at 6 1 7 830 for 750
who's our next caller hi david i'm eric
from michigan and my question to you is
how do we come to the point that were at
where we elect the President who
literally has no political experience
who is a television personality
eventually and how do we get to the
point where were so easily manipulated
as a populist well it's a couple
different ways a couple different things
there I mean number one you know the
entire no political experience thing
you're talking about it as a as a
liability and I'd many people agree with
that but many of the trumpets saw that
as the reason to vote for Donald Trump
that he was that outsider he's not the
guy who's entrenched in Washington
business as usual now we've seen that
narrative completely fall apart with his
appointment of completely establishment
Republicans lobbyists to his transition
team a completely clearly going into
this thing you know his meeting with the
Japanese Prime Minister and his daughter
who is going to be supposedly managing
his business interest in some kind of
way that it's separate from-from Donald
Trump is an individual so I think that
the voters were bamboozled on that but
needless to say the UH nevertheless the
entire no experience thing was seen as
an asset by many trumpets but why weirdo
voters so bamboozled but by this before
even before the election occurred it's a
couple of different things and we've
talked about it and I know a lot of
people are quick to blame one or two
things on the election of Donald Trump
blame it on FBI director James Comey
letters blame it on racist Trump
supporters blame it on Hillary Clinton
being a bad candidate blame it on the
DNC choosing Hillary Clinton uh early on
and stacking that the the entire playing
field against Bernie Sanders it was
really a combination right there's no
doubt that economic fears in some parts
sort of catalyzed by racism right the
fear of his spin
annex taking your job made people see
Trump's narrative is appealing it's true
to some degree but the the candidates
elected by the Democrats Hillary Clinton
had major liabilities in terms of the
entire email thing I mean I think there
was a lot going on here and then we also
have voter suppression in the background
of this well in I guess my point is is
why is it that the voters themselves are
so easily manipulated uh why is it that
the voters themselves are so easily
distracted why is it that we we there
can't there isn't a message to these
people that there's out ways for them to
draw conclusions based on critical
analysis yeah I don't think blaming
blaming anyone or anything is is
productive I think it's empowering the
populace to not be so easily manipulated
and that is to me the real tragedy of
this whole thing yeah well when you look
at Texas Board of Education uh staffers
are volunteers saying critical thinking
isn't something that we should really be
teaching in school I think you very
quickly get to up a lot of what you're
talking about is the root of the problem
and I completely agree uh with your
analysis that the lack of critical
thinking is a major major problem I
really appreciate the call we do have to
move on I hope you speak to you again in
the future gamefly is sort of like
Netflix for video games they have over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low used
price there's never any due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
free 30-day trial at gamefly offer.com /
tdps the games are shipped directly to
you with return envelopes included
there's no contracts and you can rent
games through the mobile app get the
free 30-day trial for the david pakman
show audience and support our show by
going to gamefly offer.com / tdps